foreign
Michelle and I'm going to look through
my iconic moments with E.T they made me
say iconic that was not my word I know
perfect way to show McDonald's how I
feel I go to Burger King it was the
first commercial that used another
product's name McDonald's soup Burger
King and five-year-old me which is
interesting because you know where most
five-year-olds had their parties in the
70s at McDonald's yeah it's funny I do
remember this because I wanted to eat a
burger and I found out that they uh they
blew all of the seeds on each burger and
so I couldn't eat any of them for
television and I was so bummed because
you have a five-year-old little girl on
a burger commercial and all she wants is
Burger
oh my God I'm not quite ready yet oh my
God oh my gosh
hot rollers in my hair in my New York
City Apartment that I grew up in wait
this is and I'm teasing my hair of
course I mean this is
amazing the then 17 year old was
nominated for her role as Kindle in the
soap opera All My Children
then you will leave now
I'm not going anywhere
if you don't want me here you're gonna
have to throw me out
so now how excited are you about tonight
nervous very nervous
um as you can see I have no Nails left
okay get them all off I lost it's okay I
got one the next year I was the first
person to wear a Vera Wang dress did
Vera didn't make Couture yet she only
made wedding dresses but I knew Vera
because I was an ice skater and she made
ice skating dresses and so I said could
I borrow one of your wedding dresses as
an Emmy dress and she's like well wasn't
that kind of weird I was like no it's
like a beautiful dress and so that was
the history of that dress
three years later she'd become Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and finally Buffy and not
Kendall anymore
clearly I still hadn't given up the
teasing yet also where are my eyebrows
what happened to my eyebrows
background the prom is one of my
favorite episodes of all time I did not
go to my high school prom because I went
to the Emmys and the prom you know
people always talk about the body and
hush and you know some of the other to
me the prom was everything that Buffy
was about it was it was recognize her
and she thought that she was invisible
and that they didn't know who she was
but they saw her for who she really was
Buffy Summers
class protector
people always ask me like if there's a
prop I was sad I didn't keep the
umbrella
hello ah
[Music]
screamed too this was so much fun this
was so exciting for me
[Music]
or they didn't let anybody read the
script then I was desperate to be in
Scream too I didn't care what the role
was didn't care
[Music]
laughs you can't just yell for the fun
of it it really you have to be scared
and terrified and screaming and it just
it was gut wrenching
I Know What You Did Last Summer with my
green satin dress and that Tiara that
weighed
like a good 40 pounds and what's amazing
is I am not a pageant girl so I did not
know how to wear a tiara at all I was
like can I please knock it off my head
when I run that was all I cared about
you're really scared of the movie I look
for the cute boy next to me and I grab
on and I curl in their lap is that cute
boy next to me is that Freddy walking
behind me right there it was during the
filming of I Know What You Did Last
Summer that Sarah Michelle met her
husband of 20 years uh Freddie Prince Jr
he's one of my best friends and I would
be anywhere for him they made it
official two years later my boy I'm as
happy as can be the couple have two
children their daughter Charlotte got a
shout out during her icon award speech I
have a daughter who's 13 and she wants
to go into this field as well and she's
in middle school which I think we all
remember pretty much sucks but there's a
place for people like us where we fit in
I can't speak of myself and call myself
an icon because that feels very odd but
I'm really really honored I mean I'm
hoping that this isn't some like
retirement party they're throwing me
me and summer it did win me an MTV movie
award for best kiss and I'll always go
back to Selma's mother but did you guys
have to use so much tongue
since Thomas mother always says Summer's
still we're still my best on camera kiss
um
going here
oh let's do the dangerous construction
well I signed on for the movie because
there was a kiss with uh me and um Velma
they got there's a great line where I
tell Fred that his Ascot makes him look
gay
got cut now who's the damn Zone distress
[Music]
this was so much fun so this was I
didn't have the hugest role in this
movie but they brought the Hong Kong
wire team from Matrix out to Australia
and so I would just train with them all
day long every day it was one of the
greatest experiences I've ever had
learning from them I just love your
columns they're so relatable thanks well
I try it's like I'm you or I will be
when I turn 30. Sex in the City this is
a great story I was desperate to be on
it and Darren had written me a couple
roles and I couldn't get out of Buffy to
film and I was really upset and he said
to me we're coming to La I'll make it
work so he wrote this role I worked all
day on Buffy I had like two hours in
between I had a 10 p.m call time for sex
in the city and I said are you gonna get
to me because I've been working since
like five we're gonna get to we're gonna
get two I got there at 10 p.m they got
to me at 5am or 4 30 a.m the next day so
I was delirious doing that scene but I
was also deliriously excited so big news
I have a star interested I mean I feel
like the D girl which is what she was
then is now probably running a studio
and maybe she has a place to come back
Michael Petro King are you listening
what do you think about that
oh gosh The Grudge I will I will never
forget this well first of all they did
not have hot water so it was
freezing and let me oh God it's so
creepy that is so creepy and you know
Japanese culture is a more prudish
culture so well I didn't care about what
I was wearing in the shower oh did they
care and you've never seen a set cleared
out faster like nobody wanted to see
anything
[Music]
garage was a really big deal I think for
a very long time it was the second
highest female opening movie ever I mean
I'm sure it's been beaten since then but
I would bet it's probably still in the
top five or ten because movies are still
really hard to have a soul female above
the title on her own like it's still not
really done someone asked me today
actually when the students said you know
what's it like now that like you're this
icon and people are working with you and
I said the only time I really ever
experienced that was when I was on set
with Robin
honey look I got him on the road Casino
all right
you got knocked out by a girl Robin I
can't say enough about him and I was so
lucky to not just get to work with him
but to know him as a person he changed a
lot of how I behave on set and how I
want to react to everybody else and I
was so nervous and nervous to make
suggestions and nervous to
try a joke out or any of those things
and Robin made everybody so comfortable
and he made sure everybody felt like the
big star in that room and I hope to be
just a little bit like father
[Music]
thank you
okay